our buildings consume about 40% of our
energy
and with our emissions threatening to
permanently change our climate
we need more efficient better greener
cities we can start by being smart with
what we have passive solar buildings
public transit private pedal power
identity living and Tillie working but
our food production is still a long way
from most of the people who live in the
cities built on the best arable land
vertical farming could turn this on its
head or at least its side it would bring
together a host of emerging technologies
by putting food production on the
building's we live and work in to reduce
land use pull our urban heat sinks and
drastically reduce food transport costs
modern agriculture uses 70% of the
world's available fresh water but
vertical farms could be fitted with nano
films and boost condensation and Nano
membranes would filter and clean
recycled water better water quality less
waste crop effectiveness will be boosted
by genetic engineering to select the
best genetic variants for the
environment fiber optics might provide
light with incredible energy efficiency
one square block farm 30 stories high
could yield as much food as 10 square
kilometres outdoors there are of course
hurdles the crops best suited to
vertical farming may require us to
adjust our diets but would farmers and
agribusiness take this lying down or is
it simply that our dollars are best
spent on smart simple and practical
improvements to existing infrastructure
and technology
you